على قلق اطوي المسافات خلفي والموصله تشير
الى فلسطين
الوقت يمر بطيئا كان الساعه توقفت
افتحي الشباك
[موسيقى]
فالرحله هناك تبدا بالحواجز والممرات
الامنيه وغرف التحقيق والتوقيف
بيد ان كل هذا التعب يتلاشى مع اول لحظه
عناق لسيده المدن القدس
لاجلك يا مدينه الصلاه
[موسيقى]
لاج
لك يا زهره المداء
يا قدس
ستان يجعل من قضيه القدس في ضمير كل
فلسطيني وفي ضمير كل العربي وفي ضمير كل
مسلم استطاع ان ينقلها بابعادها الثلاث
البعض الفلسطيني والبعد العربي والبعد
الاسلامي
من اريج الارض وعبقها من زيتونها العتيق
وبرتقالها الحزين ولد ضيفي في ام الفحم
بفلسطين حاملا مشاعل النور في ليل
الاحتلال
اما الاشياء يعني تقول مليح كثير من ناحيه
الدعوه من ناحيه المجتمع فادهم كثير ومن
ناحيه حتى للجيران بقى يعني اخلاق وبكى
معامله مع الجيران مع الاخ ومعي الخوات مع
الاقارب الكل بقى يحبه والكل بقى يحب
اخلاقه وتعامله
[موسيقى]
بين رصاصتين شق الرجل الباسم طريقه الطويل
متسلحا بايمانه وامله الكبير في عوده
الاقصى حرا وحرا ولو بعد حين بقت طريقته
درعا الخلطه ابقى بعيد
قدامي
الله يرضى عليه غير عنهم كلكم
تحكي لنا جدران مدينه المدائن ازقه القدس
وعتبات الاقصى حكايه هذا الشيخ الذي رفض
التسليم بالامر الواقع معلنا ان فلسطين من
بحرها الى نهرها تابى القسمه على اثنين
[موسيقى]
اخيرا بعد العذاب عذاب الحواجز وايام
عديده ونحن نحاول الدخول الى داخل
الفلسطيني زبطت معنا نحن الان في بيت
الشيخ رائد صلاح يسعد صباحك شرفت هذا
البيت حياكم الله
ونشات في ام الفحم حديثي عن هذه النشاه
كيف كانت ام الفحم انا ولدت في عام 1958
[موسيقى]
كانت ام الفحم عباره عن جنه من جنان الارض
بما كانت تحوي من اشجار الزيتون واللوزيات
بما كانت تحوي من كل اصناف الطيور
بالعشرات التي لم تكن تنقطع عن بساتين
مدينه ام الفحم
واصبح عندي هناك تلاحم
كالروح مع الجسد مع ارض مدينه ام الفحم مع
كل اهل مدينه بالفحم الطيبين الذين صبروا
في ارضهم رغم مراره المسير التي عاشوها
على مدار عقود من الزمان كم عدد افراد
اسرتك انا ولدت في اسره من سبعه اخوه
وثلاث اخوات
انا كنت رقم خمسه بين الاخوه والاخوات
والحمد لله
عشنا كاي اسره من مدينه ام الفحم في بيت
متواضع
[موسيقى]
لو تحدثنا عن علاقتك باخواتك واخوانك يعني
عرفت معلومه انه كانت ناهده هي الاقرب الى
قلبك يعني كنت انت وياه تشاركوا بموضوع
الخبز والفرن وزي ما عم نشوف اليوم طبعا
الزعتر الفلسطيني اللي ريحته ما شاء الله
يعني اللي كان يميز العلاقه اللي بيني
وبين الناهده انه كانت تمر في لحظات توتر
سريعه
بسبب طفولتي كنت انزعج بشكل سريع من بعض
حركات ناهده فكان يقع شجار سريع ثم ينقطع
الشجار وينتهي الحمد لله رب العالمين
في المرحله الثانويه
بدات باعتناق فكر الاخوان المسلمين ما سبب
هذا التاثر اولا انا بدات باعتناق الفكر
الاسلامي في دائره العامه دون ان احدد
مدرسي معينه وفي احد المرات قرات كتاب
نظريه داروين بين مؤيديها
ومعارضيها فحقيقه لما قرات هذا الكتاب
بديت اجسام طيب انا
انا مخلوق يعني ما هدفي في الحياه
ما هي رسالتي اللي يجب ان
اتبناها في مسيره حياتي تجاه نفسي واتجاه
الاخرين
هاي الاسئله كانت طول الوقت تراودني انا
اقول عليك الدينيه
من حدث عن ستينيات وسبعينيات القرن الماضي
يعني كان من المعروف قله الكتب الدينيه
داخل الخط الاخضر كيف كنت تحصل عليها كانت
الكتب الدينيه نادره جدا مع ذلك كنا نجتهد
ان نحصل على ما تيسر من كتب
ونقراها بديت في تلك الايام بقراءه سلسله
كتب مصطفى محمود حوار مع صديقي الملحد
القران الكريم محاوله لفهم عصري لغز
الحياه لغز الموت حتى قرات كتبه اللي كانت
في بدايه حياته اللي كان يحمل فيها فكر
اخر غير الفكر الاسلامي
اللي هو مر في مرحله وحده الوجود ثم انتقل
الى تبني عقيده التوحيد الحديث عن الكاتب
مصطفى محمود الله يرحمه لفت انتباهي
الحديث عن كتاب محاوله لفهم عصري لماذا
كان له الاثر الاكبر في ابناء جيلك الذين
كانوا يتوجهون الى التدين كانت الثانويه
التي كنت ادرس فيها نسخه واحده
من كتاب القران محاوله لفهم عصري وكانت
تدور بين الطلاب اللي يقراها ينقلها لغيره
وهكذا في تلك الايام كان في هناك امتداد
لفكر مصادم لفكرنا الاسلامي
كان الفكر الشيوعي وبطبيعه الحال كانت
تبدر من بعض الطلاب بعض التساؤلات اللي
كانت تزعجنا وتثيرنا كنا نرفض هذه الشبهات
الان لما وقع بين ايدينا كتاب القران
محاول لفهم عصري وبدا مصطفى محمود يؤكد ان
هذا القران عظيم هذا القران في اعجاز علمي
هذا القران يتحدث عن
علوم اللي اكتشفت قبل سنوات من عمر
البشريه وفعلا بدت مرحله تبني هاي
المفاهيم وبدينا نواجه الطلاب اللي كانوا
يستثيرون في هذه الاسئله
قائم على جهل بدليل انه كثير منهم انهم
الحمد لله تراجعوا الان هم ابناء المساجد
اما كظاهره نعم الذي تقولينه صواب نيه في
الميه كان في هناك انتشار لكن في عام
تمتعقول عمليه التاثير المباشر من قبلكم
في مجموعات اكبر مجموعات طلابيه حتى
اصبحنا امام ظاهره تسمى التائبون الى الله
ادوات التاثير حينها كيف كانت في تلك
المرحله من حياتنا يعني نحن فعلا تاثرنا
مع كتب الدكتور مصطفى محمود وبدانا نقرا
كتب اخرى لغير الدكتور مصطفى محمود ولكن
يعني ما كان عنا الثقافه المتمكنين منها
اللي ممكن احنا نتحدث هكذا ارتجالا كنا
نكتب المعلومات على ورقه ونجلس مع الطالب
اللي هو زميلنا في المدرسين ونقول له لو
سمحت بدنا نقرا هاي الورقه امامك فكل قال
رسول الله عليه الصلاه والسلام نصرت
بالشباب قال رسول الله عليه الصلاه
والسلام صدقني الشباب معلوماتنا كنا
اكرهها قراءه من جهه ثانيه في اجتمعت
جهودنا مع جهود
دعاء كرام افاضل كان في مقدمتهم اول من
ترك مدينه ام الفحم كان المرحوم الشيخ عبد
السميع كان من علماء الازهر في مصر ثم بدا
يدرس في مدينه ام الفحم في المساجد بعد
ذلك كان الدور البارز المتالق للمرحوم
الشيخ عبد الله نمر درويش ثم جاء مجموعه
من العلماء من غزه الى الضفه الغربي كانوا
كلهم الحمد لله يتناوبون على
القاء مواعظ دروس في مساجد ام الفحم انا
هيك الدراسه
وقري الجامعه كنت محتار بيض دراسه اللغه
العربيه او كانت بعضك بالشريعه وهي التي
اخترتها كيف حدث ذلك كانت البدايه انه انا
احببت اللغه العربيه لدرجه التعصب ما كنت
اطيق ان اسمع واحد من طلاب مدرستي يتكلم
ولو كلمه عبريه اللي حبب الي اللغه
العربيه الله يرحمه الاستاذ احمد حسين
علمنا كيف نحب اللغه العربيه حقيقه حبي
الى اللغه العربيه
نقلني الى حب التعلق بالفكر الاسلامي لما
وصلت الى المرحله الثانويه وبطبيعه الحال
بدي اكرر بعد المرحله الثانويه الى اين
كان امامي عده مسارات اولا اريد ان اتعلم
رسم وكانت موهبه الرسم تنمو في حياتي بشكل
ممتاز او كنت بدي اتعلم لغه عربيه في قضيه
الشريعه
في الاساس الاساس ما كانت مطروحه خياراته
احد المرات مدير المدرسه اسمه الاستاذ
جميل سالم رحمه الله عليه
دعاني مع مجموع الطلاب قال انا اكتشفت انه
في مدينه الخليل في كليه شريعه تعلم اللغه
العربيه وتعلم الشريعه الاسلاميه
ويرحبون باي طالب ياتي من فلسطينيه 48 ما
رايكم ان تتعلموا في كليه الشريعه اذا انا
بتعلم شريعه وفي نفس الوقت بتعلم لغه
عربيه بجمع بين الخيارين
وهذا اللي خلاني احسم اني اتعلم في كليه
الشريعه في مدينه الخليل الحمد لله رب
العالمين لما قررت
رحمه الله عليه والدي كان عنده تردد كان
تردده بسبب الخوف على وضعي في اجواء حكم
عسكري ولكن الحمد لله تم ترجيح الامر
واستقر الامر وبدات اتعلم في جامعه الخليل
فرصه تاكله لهذا الزعتر الفلسطيني الاصلي
من لقطه من بلادهم
تتريحوا لكم شوي وتفضلوا
بالمقابله
بفلسطيني
اقول هذا دواء قبل ان يكون غذاء
[موسيقى]
جسد شيخ رائد صلاح في شبابه وحده فلسطين
المنقسمه واقعا بفعل الاحتلال فسار في درب
العلم قاصدا مدينه الخليل لتبدا مسيرته
بعد ان قطع الشك باليقين فاصبح اكثر صلابه
في رؤيته وتجذرا في مواقفه ودرايه بالمسار
الذي تحتاجه البلاد
[موسيقى]
وجودك في الخليل لدراسه الشريعه اتاح لك
الفرصه للتعرف اكثر على مشايخ الدين في
الضفه الغربيه ككل من هم اكثر الشيوخ
الذين تاثرت بهم هم كثير الحمد لله وجزاهم
الله خير عنا حتى قيام الساعه
استطيع ان اقول كالتالي على مستوى نفس
مدينه الخليل
كان الاستاذ المقرئ محمد رشاد الشريف كان
هناك كثير من خطباء المساجد من يلقون دروس
في الايام العاديه في المسجد الابراهيمي
في مسجد القزازين كيف تعامل اهل الخليل مع
طلبه ام الفحم وفلسطينيه الداخل كما
يوصفون اهل الخليل بدون استثناء حرصوا
علينا كما لو كنا ابناء لكل اسره في مدينه
الخليل تنافسوا ان يرعون ونحن في سيرنا
الى المساجد لاداء صلاه الجمعه او بقيه
الصلوات هم الذين ارشدون
الى المكاتب الكبيره التي منها بدانا
نشتري الكتب الاسلاميه الكثيره التي كنا
محرومين منها قبل ذلك ودائما كانوا يعطونا
لغه التشجيع حتى نكون من المتالقين بين
الطلاب في كليه الشريعه رغم هذا التشجيع
الا انك بعد فتره من الدراسه الجامعيه
قررت الانسحاب من ثم عدت للدراسه لماذا
عندما بدات بالدراسه في الاشهر الاولى
واكتشفت ان معظم التدريس كان يركز على
موضوع الشريعه
وبعض الدروس كانت للغه العربيه
وجدت نفسي انني اريد ان اعيد النظر في
قرار الالتحاق بكليه الشريعه بديت ابحث عن
امكانيه ان انتقل الى كليه لغه عربيه
في بيرزيت او في كليه الدعوه واصول الدين
في القدس متردد بدك اللغه العربيه تمام
ضليت متعلق باللغه العربيه
ولكن يعني في نهايه الامر بعض الاخوه قال
لي لا يوجد امكانيه ان نفصل بين التفسير
وبين اللغه العربيه انت عندما تتعلم تفسير
انت تتعلم اللغه العربيه وهذا حقيقه انت
عندما تتعلم اصول الفقه مبني على فهم
اللغه العربيه انت عندما تتعلم الفقه
الاسلامي
مبني ايضا على اللغه العربيه
فقررت اني ابقى توكلت على الله سبحانه
وتعالى الحمد لله انني اخترت اختيار
الصواب ان شاء الله تعالى بعد شهر من مدى
الدراسه في الخليل عدت لاول مره الى ام
الفحم وحينها القيت اول
خطبه الجمعه
والمعلومات اللي عندي انه تم انتقادك بشكل
كبير
ليش شو اللي صار يعني بعد دراستي شهر واحد
فقط في كليه الشريعه عدت الى مدينه ام
الفحم فقالوا لي هناك مسجد اسمه مسجد قباء
لا يوجد امام لصلاه الجمعه انت مطالب ام
تخطب الجمعه
فوقفت على قول الله تعالى
الهاكم التكاثر
وبنيت خطبتي على هذه الايه صعدت على
المنبر لما بديت اخطب الجمعه قرات الخطبه
بسرعه فائقه جدا يعني لدرجه ان الناس ما
كانت تدرك الكلمات التي كنت اقولها فقيل
لي لم نفهم شيء سمعنا ضجيج
طبعا كانت هيئه الخطبه
ومنها بدانا نجتهد ان نتعلم
اصول الخطابه
وكنت تتردد على المنابر بشكل دائم وفي
احدى المرات التقيت بالشيخ احمد ياسين
تفاصيل هذا اللقاء ما هي هو اللقاء
كالتالي دخلت مره من المرات الى مسجد يعرف
باسم مسجد الجبارين وهو المسجد القديم
الاول في كل حاره الجبارين
فوجدت هناك مجموعه من الدعاء يجلسون على
هيئه حلقه في المسجد
طبيعه الحال اقتربت منهم واخذت اصافحهم
واحد واحد فجيت على احدهم ومديت ايدي حتى
اصافحه هو ما مد ايده فاستغربت
فبعد ان انهيت مصافحه الجميع طبعا سالنا
عن هذا الحال اللي كان فيه فقالوا لي هو
يعاني من شلل لذلك لا يستطيع ان يمد يده
هاي كانت بدايه التقائي مع الشيخ احمد
ياسين رحمه الله عليه
[موسيقى]
978 لماذا قمت بتاسيس المهرجانات
الاسلاميه في هذا العام
فصاعدا بدانا
نجتهد لنبحث عن كل وسيله
من خلالها ننقل الدعوه الاسلاميه الى
الناس كان هناك معروف الاعراس التراثيه
الفلسطينيه فقلنا لماذا لا نفكر ان نقيم
عرس اسلامي نريد ان يكون هناك كلمات
موعظه للناس مع اناشيد ذات رساله ايضا
دعويه استمريت على هذا النهج حتى ابواب
التخرج عام 1980 وتم اعتقالك لاول مره
وحينها كنت تسعى انت ورفاقك لتاسيس اسره
الجهاز
دعينا الان نقول حقائق تاريخيه انا
الحقيقه ما كنت في اسره الجهاز كنت اعرف
ان هناك شيء اسمه اسره جهاد
ولكن
يعني الاحداث توافقت
انه كان في هناك عمل ما
اللي هو
كان له ارتباط في اسره الجهاد
اللي هو كان السبب في اعتقالي ما هو ذلك
السبب يعني كان في صعود للتيار الاسلامي
في ذلك الوقت كبير كان صعود كبير جدا
المخاوف وخلى العيون عليكم
طيب هنا لحظه الاعتقال هذه ما التهم التي
وجهت اليك كانت عباره عن حدث من احداث
متعلقه باسره الجهاد ذاك الحدث اعتبر في
نظر المؤسسه الاسرائيليه
عمل امني ضد مصلحه الدوله وبناء عليه تم
اعتقال كل من ظنوا انه له دور في هذا
الحدث هذا الاعتقال
احدث امتحان صعب
لمسيره الدعوه الاسلاميه الناس خافت لا شك
هذا احدث مرحله جمود في الدعوه الاسلاميه
في حياتك فانت ملاحق منذ ذلك الحين ودائم
يعني دائما ما يتم اعتقالك والتحقيق معك
في تجربه السجن الاولى والاعتقال الاولى
بكيت اكثر من مره شو كنت تفكر لما كنت
تبكي كل مراحل سجني اللي تعددت كانت تمر
لحظات حنين الى البيت الى الام الى الزوجه
الى الابناء الى البنات
الى مشهد
الافطار في رمضان الى مشهد صباح يوم العيد
الى مشهد صناعه كعك العيد في البيت لا
شكها كانت تمر وهي تمر في مخيله كل
اسير سياسي ما في شك في ذلك هسا في هاي
اللحظات هل كانت دموعنا تنزل بعترف نعم
انا شخصيا بعترف كانت دموعي تنزل عندما
كنت اتذكر هذه الاجواء
[موسيقى]
بعد مخاض عسير اثمرت خطى رائد صلاح ورفاقه
في تاسيس النواه الاولى لولاده الحركه
الاسلاميه متكئا في ذلك على العمل
الجماهري الذي تمدد حتى تجاوز حدود الخط
الاخضر
لم تكن اطول تجربه اعتقال تم الافراج عنك
وفي عام
1984 انت
وبعض افراد اسره الجهاد قمتم باعاده ترتيب
البيت الداخلي كيف عملتم على اعاده تنظيم
صفوفكم بعد الخروج من سجون الاعتقال بعد
تجربه
اسره الجهاد
بدانا في مرحله المشروع التربوي تربيه جيل
تربيه اسلاميه شامله بدانا بمرحله اقامه
المؤسسات
ذات الاختصاصات المختلفه حتى تبني ارضيه
صلبه للدعوه الاسلاميه
ولما بدينا في هاي المشاريع اذكر تماما
بدينا نتساءل طب احنا في مرحله جديده ايش
اسمنا الان
في الماضي قبل اسره الجهاد كان يقال عنا
مره باسم الشباب المسلم او كانوا يقولون
عنا اسم التائبون او المشايخ
اسماء كثيره طب الان شو بدنا نسمي حالنا
كل ما سبق ما حدا الطريق لولاده الحركه
الاسلاميه بالضبط هنا اتفقنا ان نطلق على
انفسنا اسم الحركه الاسلاميه
سعى الاحتلال الى
تقطيع صينيين جغرافيا وفصل فلسطينيه
الداخل عن غزه والضفه وبالعكس انتم سعيتم
الى افشال هذا المخطط كان طبيعه اعمالنا
هي عباره عن اعمال اللي تصنع لحمه الحال
ما بين كل قطاعات شعبنا الفلسطيني
يعني لما بدينا في مرحله
الدعوه الاولى وجدنا انفسنا مضطرين ان
نستعين بدعاء اكفاء من الضفه الغربيه
والحمد لله رب العالمين
جاؤونا بمدد بارك الله فيهم من كل انحاء
الضفه الغربيه ووصل الامر ان جاء دعاء
ايضا من غزه
فكان هذا عباره عن صناعه تواصل
بين ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني الان تقدمنا
خطوه الى الامام
بدانا بمهرجان الفن الاسلامي مهرجان الفن
الاسلامي كان يستقطب فرق نشيد شعراء فرق
مسرح من الضفه الغربيه من غزه من فلسطينيه
جماهير غفيره كانت تاتي من كل هذه المناطق
اما لتشارك في مسابقات مهرجان الفن
الاسلامي او كحضور
ايضا هذا اوجد نوع من التواصل بين ابناء
الشعب الفلسطيني الواحد بعد ذلك جاءت
مرحله اخرى قوه امتداد عددي
للحركه الاسلاميه ومره واحده وجدنا انفسنا
مما لا شك فيه الطيار الشعبي رقم واحد في
كل ال 48 بدون مناسب
[موسيقى]
لم يدم الوفاق بين مكونات الحركه
الاسلاميه بذور الشقاق روسرت على ارض
الحركه والتباينات اصبحت من اوضح الواضحات
بين فريق يرفض الانخراط في انتخابات
الكنيست واخر يدعو الى فن الممكن والعمل
ضمن قواعد الواقعيه السياسيه
[موسيقى]
تاثير شخصي لاي شخص كان هناك مفاهيم يجب
ان نحافظ عليها
وقيم
واصول للحركه الاسلاميه يجب ان نحافظ
عليها حتى تبقى حركه اسلاميه
المشاركه في الكنيست الاسرائيلي اكثر من
مره
اكثر من مره عرض علي في
عام 2003 لما تم اعتقالي مع الاخوه رهائن
الاقصى كنا لا زلنا في الاعتقال
نحاكم وفجاه جاءنا وسيط قال انا وسيط من
قبل المخابرات انتم مطالبون ان تقوموا
بثلاث اعمال العمل الاول ان تعلنوا عن
استعدادكم لخوض انتخابات الكنيست العمل
الثاني انه انت انا المطلوب مني ان اكتب
عن التعايش الشيء الثالث انه انتم تبتعدوا
عن النشاط المربوط بالمسجد الاقصى اذا
وافقتوا على هذه الشروط الثلاث سيكون هناك
مفاوضات تؤدي الى خروجكم من السجن فانا
طبعا سمعت حتى النهايه قلت له رجاء حار
كلهم عرضت هاي المطالب على المعتقلين
وقالوا لي وضعنا هاي المطالب تحت اقدامنا
كلو بهاي الجواب
وفعلا هو نقل هذا الجواب هذا لم يعجب
الاحتلال وانت من بت يعرف بشيخ الاقصى
وهنا لدي سؤال هل فعلا عرض عليك 50 مليون
شيكل اي ما يعادل 15 مليون دولار للتخلي
عن نصره القدس نعم نعم هذا كان عندما كنت
رئيس بلديه ام الفحم لما بدانا في اوج
نشاطنا في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
بالذات لما بدانا في مسيره اعمار المصلى
المرواني برعايه هيئه الاوقاف الاسلاميه
كيف وصل لك هذه
جاءنا موظفي وبشكل واضح صريح
بيقول احنا بنعرض عليكم باسم مكتب رئيس
الحكومه
هبه هبه لبلديه ام الفحم 50 مليون شيكل
طبعا بس طلب واحد اللي هو انه انتم
تتوقفوا عن الاعمال في المسجد الاقصى
بالضبط هاي كانت روح الحديث تبعه فطبعا
اخذ الجواب المناسب
باذن الله رب العالمين احنا كملنا عملنا
الحمد لله
يعني بالجواب كان بالاعمال يعني لم تتوقف
عن دعم الاقصى وكنت تنظف المساجد بنفسك
وتقوم باصلاح الاناره وتجديدها طبعا طبعا
حاشا لله ان نركع لاغراءات دنيويه
ونقطع انفسنا عن المسجد الاقصى المبارك
يعني لو قطعنا انفسنا عن المسجد الاقصى
المبارك نحن قطعنا انفسنا معنا ذلك عن
القران الكريم
ومعنى ذلك قطعنا انفسنا عن الكعبه وقطعنا
انفسنا عن المسجد النبوي معنى ذلك قطعنا
انفسنا عن كل الامه الاسلاميه من يضل
لنفسه ذلك ومستحيل
[موسيقى]
تعرضت لاكثر من محاوله اغتيال على اول
محاوله كانت عام 1998 ضعنا في كواليس هذه
المحاوله في عام
قامت قوات اسرائيليه بمهاجمه خيمه
الاعتصام في اراضي الروحه
وخلال الاقتحام
تعرضت لضرب شديد جدا حتى
سقطت على الارض
شبه مغمى علي
واحدهم حاول ان يلقي حجر كبير علي
بهدف ايذائي
ونتيجه هذا الايذاء كانت قد تصل الى حد
الموت ثم كان عام 2000 عندما كانت هناك
بدايات
بدات باقتحام
شارون للمسجد الاقصى المبارك على اثرها
كانت مسيرات في كل الداخل الفلسطيني 48
كنت في مسيره في مدينه ام الفحم وتم اطلاق
رصاصه مطاطيه عليه من قبل قناص وفعلا اصبت
بالجانب الايسر من جبينه وقلت على اثرها
الى مشفى في مدينه ام الفحم كان اسمه مشفى
الحياه والحمد لله ربنا حفظ وسلم كل هذه
الاعتداءات
قياسيا كانت بسيطه بالنسبه لما وقع علي في
سجن الاخير عندما كنت معزول لوحدي
في اكثر من سجن كان اخرها في سجن هشكما في
عسقلان
في هذه الفتره اللي قضيت فيها 17 شهر
متواصله في العزل كان الاعتداء علي
يستهدف ابشع شيء ممكن ان يفكر به الانسان
وهو
[موسيقى]
في هاي الاحداث كان الهدف هو عمليه
اغتيال نفسيتي
اغتيال مطلق اغتيال معنوي ابعد من ذلك
كان الهدف
هو عمليه قتل بطيء
قتل قتل جذري قتل جذري لنفسيتي ابعد من
ذلك دعيني اقولها بصراحه كان الهدف هو
عمليه ضرب
في عقلي حتى اخرج
انسان غير طبيعي غير سويه
[موسيقى]
في عام 2003
تم اعتقالك لكن الحكايه ليست هنا بعد يوم
واحد من الاعتقال توفى الوالد
وحاولت وحرصت
ان تتواجد في الجنازه ما الذي حدث
الذي حدث انني كنت قرب سرير والدي رحمه
الله عليه
فجاه
تقدم مني رجل
ما عرفت انه من رجال المخابرات
وقال لي اريد ان اكلمك
دقائق معدوده خرجنا من مبنى المستشفى
فوجدت انه على باب المستشفى الرئيس
كان هناك سيارات واضح جدا انها سيارات
الشرطه
من هناك تم اعتقالي ثم جاء خبر وفاه
الوالد في هاي الحاله طبعا
كان هناك طلب تقدم به المحامي الذي كان
يمثلني
ايضا
بدعم من رئيس بلديه ام الفحم في حينه كان
دكتور سليمان احمد
وتم كفالتي من قبل رئيس البلديه ان اخرج
لاشارك في الجنازه فقط
غسيل الاموال
التهمي هي يعني اصبحت لائحه اتهام تعود
على نفسها طوال الوقت
تقريبا في كل الملفات التي حكمت بها
مع بعض تعديلات جمله هون تحذف جمله هون
تضاف اما الاطار العام هو والاطار العام
والادله التي استخدمها الاحتلال الاتهامك
بغسل الاموال انا شخصيا اجزم واقول لم يكن
هناك اي دليل
ان
العقليه التي حاولت ان تدخلنا السجن بكل
ثمن ماذا ادعى قالت هذا في ظاهره عمل
انساني ولكن ما وراء السطور هو يقوي
البنيه التحتيه
للارهاب الفلسطيني وعلى هذا الاساس تمت
ادامتنا وتم دخولنا الى السجن
ونؤكد لكم ان المؤسسه الاسرائيليه التي
بدات منذ اربعه اسابيع
بجريمه هدم جزء من المسجد الاقصى المبارك
لخطه فادي
ايضا تم اتهامك بانك تحرض على خطاب
الكراهيه يعني الاحتلال ذهب وبحث في اغلب
خطب الجمعه التي كنت
تقوم بها ليجد لك التهم ويلصقها
ما الذي يخشاه الاحتلال من كلمات
وخطب رائد صلاح هم لم يدينوا اقوالي كما
هي في يوم من الايام هم اول اقوال كما
يريدون
وادانوني بناء على تاويلهم لاقوالهم امي
لا يريدون خطاب يعبر عن ثوابتنا الاسلامي
العروبيه الفلسطينيه التي تؤكد حقنا في
ارضنا حقنا في القدس المبارك حقنا في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك الحق الابدي الوحيد
في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
يقف خلف هذا الطرح والى ماذا يرميه قبل
اعتقال في عام 2003 انا مع الاخوه رهائن
الاقصى
جاءنا شخصيه
هو يعرف نفسه انه مستشرك احنا جئنا ندعوكم
للقاء مع رئيس الحكومه شارون قلت له شو
الهدف قال انا ما بعرف بدي استفسر فبعد
فتره اتصل مره اخرى
وبكل احنا ما بنقدر نقول لك شو الهدف قلت
له اعتبر انه جواب
لن نشارك في اللقاءات كان ستندمون
حقي اني ارفض اللقاء ليش ذنب
اقتحمت المخابرات الاسرائيليه مؤسسه
الاقصى ونهبوا وثائقها ما اهميه هذه
المؤسسه كي تستهدف وهذه الوثائق هي توثق
لمقدسه
اللي تمثل جذورنا في ارضنا تمثل جذور
تاريخنا وحضارتنا كانت ضربه يعني موجعه
ولكن ليست في مستوى حظر الحركه الاسلاميه
ولكن كانت ضرب
دفعت ايضا بعض الصحف العبريه الى المطالبه
بقتلك الا تخشى ان يتم تنفيذ تلك
التهديدات التي تعاني والاحيانا بعض الصحف
العبريه بالكميه
من المقالات اللي كتبت باسلوب تحريضي
تطالب باغتيالي في مواقع تواصل عبريه لا
تصدق كم عددها منهم من يقول بصراحه يجب
تصفيته لماذا لا يزال حيا حتى الان انا
ادعو الى قتله
[موسيقى]
هذه التهديدات كادت ان تتحقق عندما تعرضت
ايضا لمحاوله اغتيال في اصول الحريه عام
2020 محاوله اغتيال في اسطول الحريه كشفت
الايام معلومات
تؤكد ان المحاوله كانت جاده مئه بالمئه
احدهم من
الذين كانوا يعملون في الاجهزه الامنيه
الرسميه الاسرائيليه اعترف بشكل صريح وقال
بالحرف الواحد
لصاحب مطعم عربي
عنا في الداخل الفلسطيني انا كنت موكل
بمهمه واحده عندما اقتحمنا اسطول الحريه
ان اغتال الشيخ رائد صلاح لما اعلنوا عن
خبر اختياري
ظنوا انهم فعلا نفذوا جريمتهم بعد ان
قتلوا شبيهه الشهيد التركي رحمه الله عليه
اول ما صار في هناك اقتحام من قبل قوات
البحريه الاسرائيليه
اولا صوروني ثم كنت مقيد طبعا بايدي جاء
احدهم وهمس في اذني قال في هناك رجل يريد
ان يكلمك
فخذوني الى غرفه
من غرف السفينه فعلا دخلت كان رجل واضح
انه ليس من بالقوات البحريه لباس ولباس
رسمي عادي
فنظر اليه قال مين انت قلت له انا رائد
صلاح
قال لي في معك
الشيء الان يثبت شخصيته بطاقه شخصيه جواز
سفر قلت له صادر وكل شيء فش معيشه وانا
على قناع جاء فقط لهدف واحد ليتاكد هل
قتلت ام لا زلت حي كانت القضيه مدبره
مع انطلاق موجه التطبيع بعد اتفاقيات
ابرهام وجد الشيخ رائد صلاح نفسه محاصرا
ليس من الاحتلال الذي يتربص به الدوائر
وانما من الشقيق الذي يقاسمه العروبه
والدين
في عام 2015 كان لك تصريح قلت بان مسؤول
العربي حرض الاحتلال على حظر الحركه
الاسلاميه هل لك ان تقول لي من هو من
مسؤول العربي طبعا يعني مضطر اني اعتذر
انا مضطر اني اعتذر في وثائق ليس وان
الكشف عنها اللي تؤكد انه البعض
حاول يقول لنا بشكل واضح كانه كانه بثوب
نصيحه انه
مالكم ومال المسجد الاقصى
بامكانكم ان تصلوا وتروحوا خلاص هاي
المسجد
يقول بانه رائد صلاح يرمي التهم جزافا له
حقا يقول ذلك واعذر
ولكن
كما نقول في مثلنا العامي كل شيء في وقت
حلو طب ما الذي يدفع
نشاط يدعو
الى فلسطينيين على استعاده اراضيه الان
من
جعل مصلحته مربوطه
مع
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه وليس مع القضيه
الفلسطينيه طب فيكم
تحملون هويات اسرائيليه نحن لا ننتقد
التطبيع
بمنطق مزاجي كل شيء يصطدم مع ثوابتنا
الاسلاميه العروبيه الفلسطينيه مرفوض هاي
اولا ثانيا عندما فرض علي
ان احمل بطاقه شخصيه رسميه
هذا لا يعني
انني
اتبرا من امتداد الاسلام العروب الفلسطيني
من اثار نكبه فلسطين
قد فرض عليه مثل هذا الحال
ولذلك لا يمكن ان يعتبر هذا كانه
شيء مساوي للتطبيق
[موسيقى]
بعيدا عن الاشتباك المستمر مع الاحتلال
يعيش الشيخ رائد صلاح ببساطه وتواضع في
بيته ولا ينسى بطبيعه الحال ان يعبر عن
وجدانه بيديه عبر الرسم او بلسانه عبر
الشعر
اخترنا هذا الموقع لان هذا الموقع يملك
زوج ابنتك الى جانب ذلك هناك عنا متحف
الرسام العالمي المرحوم عاصم ابو شقره
اللي هو اخوي ايضا هو بحد ذاته متحف رسم
ثابت دائم وانت لو شيخا كنت اخترت ان تكون
رسام وهنا لدينا عدد من الرسومات التي قمت
برسمها اثناء فتره الاعتقال التي كانت على
فترات من اين كنت تستوحي
الافكار
الرسوم الموجوده الان اما تعبير عن
مناسبات مرت علي وانا في السجن
او محاوله العوده الى
ذكريات اللي عشتها حتى في ايام الطفوله
فهذه الرسوم كلها انا رسمت في داخل السجن
في مرحله العزل لتنقلت فيها
بيمتلى السجود جمعت الصوره بالكلمه انت
شاعر ايضا واطلقت مؤخرا ديوان جديد
الديوان الاخير باسم الربيع النبوي وهذا
الديوان كل نظمته في داخل السجن هل انا
نصنع جزء بسيط
يمكن اكون مقدمتها
يعني نظمتها لوالدتي اللي بقول فيها ما
اعظم قولي يا امي هو لحن الرحمه والسلم يا
نوره عيوني يا قلبي
افديك بروحي وبدمي
لا ابالغ ذا قلت هي مدرسي في الصمود
فالصبر مدرسه سياسيه من الطراز الاول يعني
هي مدد روحاني مدد نفسي مدد عاطفي وهذا ما
تحاول نقله
او لا يمكن ان اصل لمستوى نجاحها وان اعطي
اولادي واحفادي كما اعطتني اما بدي اجتهد
بديش تطلعي لنا باب
حطه
يلا شد حالك
[موسيقى]
انا دائما اطمع ان يتبنوا رؤيه الانسان
المتفائل الطريق قد يكون طويل ولكن من صار
عليه سيصل اول تج
ربه انت ملاحق وانت الممنوع من السفر ايضا
اليوم ماذا يقول رائد صلاح لسجانه من يبكر
في السجن هو السجان اما الاسير فسيخرج من
السجن وفي نهايه الامر
السجن سيبقى يحمل دلالتين دلاله كرامه
للاسير السياسي
ودلاله هزيمه
لقضبان السجون
[موسيقى]
وانت شيخ الاقصى ما هو الخطر الاكبر الذي
يهدد الاقصى الاب لابد ان نكون على تواصل
دائم
كالتحام الروح مع الجسد هكذا يجب ان نبقى
مع المسجد الاقصى ونورث هذه العلاقه
لاجيالنا جيل بعد جيل
ما بقي الزعتر والزيتون
[موسيقى]
احيانا تمضين الحياه الى مسارات لم نخطط
لها
[موسيقى]
لكننا نحتاج لاختيار الزاويه المضيئه
والسير نحوها
[موسيقى]
طريقي مع الشيخ رائد صلاح انتهى لكنني
ساكمل الطريقه مترقبه لقاء شخص اخر مع
جانب اخر جديد
[موسيقى]